let's go to our next caller we are
taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750 our next
caller is from the 315 area code caller
what's your name and where are you
calling from hello this is jade from
upstate New York great what's on your
mind I don't know if you've seen this
but it seems that house Republican bill
1275 otherwise known as Trump's health
care plan is actually called the world's
greatest health care plan of 2017 can
you confirm if that's true and if so am
i living in the matrix I have not seen
that did you hear about that Pat the
world's greatest hell evident I did not
hear the desert is called I didn't hear
that but it seems to limit it to just
being the greatest health care plan in
2017 which it maybe it's the only one
that I've seen put forth in 2017 from a
grammatical standpoint it doesn't really
tell us much I heard they were calling
it the big Lee tremendous health for all
plan that's what I read on a bright bart
or something like that no i don't know i
don't know if that's true but i can
check into it that'd be wonderful thank
you I appreciate the call